So now that we know that each
application saves a lot of memory.
And there is much less physical
memory than all the applications
actually can access.
The question is where
is the missing memory?
So let's say we have one
application with four pages.
Another application with
let's say four pages.
A physical memory with let's
say four physical frames.
Let's say that each of these
applications is actually using all of
its pages.
Because there are only four.
In this application there
is a four entry page table.
That for every page tells us
which frame contains it and
it could be any frame in memory.
This application also has some of
its pages in physical memory but
obviously there is not enough physical
memory for all of these pages.
So the question is where
are the rest of them.
And the answer is,
they're on the hard disk.
So some of these pages
are not actually in memory,
they're actually stored on
the hard drive in the system.
These pages can not be directly accessed
by the processor because the processor
can only really access through loads and
stores in the physical memory.
So if the processor ever tries to access
one of these they need to be brought
from the disk before
they can be accessed.
We will shortly see how that works,
but for
now just remember that because the
virtual memory of all the applications
can significantly exceed the size of the
physical memory, some of the memory that
the applications think they have is on
the disk, not really in memory at all.